يملك البنك المركزي الروسي اكثر من 300
مليار دولار من الاموال المجمده قانونيا
تعود ملكيه هذه الاصول للدوله الروسيه
لكنها لا تستطيع التصرف بها بسبب العقوبات
وتقدر الاموال الخاصه بمواطنين يحملون
الجنسيه الروسيه بنحو 30 مليار دولار تصنف
هذه الاموال في فئه الملكيه الفرديه
الخاصه
خبراء في القانون يؤكدون وجود اختلاف جذري
بين تجميد الاصول ومصادرتها فالتجميد خطوه
تحتمل ان تكون قانونيه اما المصادره
فتحتاج الى قوانين لحالات خاصه لا يمكن
تعميمها ورغم جهود مشرعين امريكيين في وضع
قوانين تمكن الرئيس من استخدام الاموال
الروسيه المجمده الا ان القوانين النافذه
واضحه يمنح قانون سلطه الطوارئ الاقتصاديه
الدوليه رئيس الولايات المتحده السلطه كي
يجمد الاصول المملوكه لاجانب بما في ذلك
ممتلكات دول اجنبيه والتجميد في هذه
الحاله يهدف الى تدمير القيمه الاقتصاديه
للاصول بتجريم محاوله التعامل بها او
الحصول على منافع منها لكن التجميد في هذه
الحاله لا يعني تغيير ملكيه تلك الاصول
وبحسب خبراء هناك استثناء نادر جدا في هذا
القانون يمنح الرئيس الحق في مصادره
الممتلكات الاجنبيه والتصرف فيها
والاستثناء يكون
او وقوع اعمال عدائيه من قبل دوله اجنبيه
او مواطنين اجانب فما هي المشاكل
القانونيه التي تعرقل المصادره يميز خبراء
القانون بين الاصول الخاصه التي جمدتها
حكومات غربيه وممتلكات الدوله مثل
احتياطيات العملات الاجنبيه للبنك المركزي
الروسي في حاله الاصول الخاصه تعني
الضمانات القانونيه انه لا يسمح للدول
الغربيه بمصادرتها الا في حال اثبات انها
عائدات من نشاطات اجراميه وعليه فمصادرتها
تشكل تعديا على الحقوق القانونيه وحقوق
الانسان الاساسيه لصعوبه اثبات الجرم اما
الاصول العامه للدول فعاده ما ترتبط
باتفاقيات استثمار ثنائيه او دوليه ومن ثم
فان مصادرتها قد تعرض الدول المعنيه
لمطالبات قانونيه في محاكم دوليه
من جهه اخرى تطرح اصول الدوله مثل
احتياطيات البنك المركزي مشاكل مختلفه
لكنها شائكه ايضا لانها مغطاه بما يسمى
الحصانات السياديه وهو تفاهم يقضي بان لا
تستولي دوله على ممتلكات دوله اخرى في
جميع الاحوال فان روسيا تبدو مستعده للرد
في حال المصادره اذ وقع الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين مرسوما يقضي بوضع الاصول الاجنبيه
في روسيا تحت سيطره الدوله المؤقته او تحت
اداره مؤقته اذا تمت مصادره اصول روسيه في
الخارج